[music playing]
So now, I'm running.
And I have no plan.
And no idea where I was heading.
[screaming]
And my heart is literally
just pounding through my chest
to the point where
I think I'm actually
going to have a heart attack.
I just kept repeating to myself
in my head I was like, I just--
I just can't get caught.
I can't get caught.
Stop!
I've got into sort of
like this undergrowth.
And I was getting scratched
all over my face and my arms.
[heartbeat thumping]
I've come out the other side.
And you know, I'm like a yard.
And I've seen a
hole in the fence.
I'm halfway through this hole.
I think I'm going to make it.
[gun cocking]
And then I hear this voice.
Stop.
Don't move.
And at that point,
I knew it was over.
I knew if I'd done any
sort of sharp movements
and that he's probably going
to pull the trigger, you know?
And I'd be dead.
He then kicks me.
And before I know it, there's
like three or four of them.
They're all just
like kicking me.
[grunting]
[screaming]
They marched me
back to the vehicle.
Then, I'm seeing O
just casually chatting
to this police officer.
And I was just in
complete shock.
He betrayed me
massively, like probably
the biggest betrayal
you could have
in that-- in that business.
I was just seething.
I was fuming inside.
I just wanted to
grab hold of him.
But the future
wasn't in my hands.
They give, you know,
life sentences,
and you know, the death
sentence for drugs in Thailand.
And I am like completely
[bleep] to be honest.
So after that, I was
taken to a safe house.
You know, my mind just
still going round and round
and doing somersaults.
I remember thinking I'd
come to Thailand, you
know, start a new life,
build the relationship back
up with my dad.
And here I was.
My dad would find out the hard
way when any word got around
about what had just happened.
You know, I was just left
handcuffed to this bed.
And I was there all night.
And my body was craving ice.
I was going through like
cold turkey, basically.
There's only one place
that I'll be going.
They call it a Monkey House,
a hell hole, basically.
[speaking thai]
You know, they eventually
put me back in the truck.
[speaking thai]
And they drove me to
a prison in Bangkok.
[dog barking]
I remember seeing like the wall.
I just didn't know what
was on the other side.
That was the scary bit.
Are they going to
sort of target me?
Is anything can happen to me?
This could be my future for,
you know, a very long time.
I didn't know how long.
[speaking thai]
And they basically said
take all your clothes off.
It felt awful.
Your self-dignity is just gone.
And they're sort of checking in
my mouth, in my genital area.
Just don't even feel like
you're a person anymore.
You know?
You just feel like a bit
of meat that, you know,
you're just being
treated that way.
This place was just like,
you know, a living hell hole.
And this was now my new reality.
The officer has taken
me to the cell block.
Got all these prisoners,
you know, they're
[speaking thai],,
which is like Thai
for-- they say for foreigner.
And I remember looking
over and seeing
two Thai inmates in
front of this guard
who was holding a stick.
The next minute, and
he's just smashed it down
on the fingertips of the inmate.
He's going to
smash, smash, smash.
No emotion at all.
At that point, I thought
there's no way I want
to be causing trouble in there.
That's for sure.
It was actually
dark at that point.
So it's like, what now?
And then, one of the
guys, he was like, you.
He's like, you sit here.
[speaking thai]
It was just so crammed.
And like, there was just
no space at all in there.
I was sleeping on a hard cold
floor with a water bottle
as-- as my pillow.
It was just soul destroying.
I felt really agitated.
I was getting the cold
sweats because my body
was still craving ice.
[moaning]
Got this guy, at the
same point, shouting.
And you know, he's having
some sort of nightmare.
[shouting]
That was the most
depressed and helpless
that I've ever felt in my life,
to be honest, at that point.
Everything that I'd heard
about what these Thai
prisons were like, it was true.
And it was happening, you
know, in front of my eyes.
And it's like your
worst nightmare.
[music playing]